but it's also not a normal summer this
year it's a quarantine summer
and so we've kind of been very bored at
home haven't we
yes yes and so now we've resorted to
making our own pizza
[Music]
it is lunch time or actually it's way
past lunch time it's actually like three
o'clock or something now but isaac has
been wanting to make pizza
at home homemade pizza i don't know
we've never made homemade pizza
we've never made homemade pizza isaac
out of all the things we always
cook out of this house pizza is not one
of those things and that's
always something that you always order i
don't know that always seems harder to
make pizza than it is to just simply
order it because it comes to your
doorstep in like 10 minutes
anyways we are gonna make pizza today
and i just finished
grabbing all the ingredients i got some
mozzarella cheese pepperoni
and the thing that we're making from
scratch is the pizza dough
ready isaac yeah all right what are you
playing
i'm playing seed thieves so steve wanted
to play with isaac because
steve also plays man
seeing steve and sia thieves at the same
time is very hard
yeah you hear that that's been all day
we are having
construction in the background if you
didn't know backyard's coming out nicely
all right so isaac i got pepperoni
mozzarella cheese and you wanted
the actual block of cheese so that we
could
actually do our own shredding um this is
what we didn't have i needed to get
baking powder because we're doing a
yeast less pizza dough i didn't know
pizza dough was complicated like that i
didn't know you actually had to use real
baking things like yeast
because to me at this point due to my
lack of baking experience
real baking in my to my knowledge is
anything that has to do with yeast and
you know what i realized we did have
yeast we have two packets of yeast these
things were very hard to find during the
early days of pandemic
so this is like gold in the baking world
nah it's hard because it takes longer
too you have to like let it settle and
like there's science behind it and all
that and you have to use a certain
temperature of water
sounds like a big headache i haven't
opened my mind up to the whole baking
world just yet
oh yeah pizza sauce we need some of this
can you grab a big
the biggest bowl we got down behind you
the really really big one so we got this
big boy right here first things first
let's go ahead and heat up
the this is the oven we got this guy
right here combined
flour baking soda
and salt we need two and a half cups of
flour
mmm so fun all right cool we're done
with the flour nice
one teaspoon of salt start moving ah
alright next we're gonna find a whisk
and mix it all together nice
are you having fun yeah summer time is a
time
for kids to go outside and have fun
summer camps are a common thing getting
activities but it's also not a normal
summer
this year it's a quarantine summer and
so we've kind of been
very bored at home haven't we yes yes
and so now we've resorted to making our
own pizza
no it's positive this is good we're
learning something now we can we can
make our own pizza anytime anywhere yeah
okay slowly add water to this how much
water
three quarter cup and two tablespoons
fill that up three quarters
watch off bam ooh science is
happening oh i think we messed up
actually
uh we're supposed to combine the water
and the oil first
in a separate jug or a cup so what do we
do now
uh we just add in the oil now and we're
gonna have to just
make do with what uh if it comes out
lumpy it comes out lumpy we don't have
any idea what we're doing
we need mom yes mom is very good at
reading instructions
perfect to make mistakes
trials and tribulations and learn that
way because then it really sinks in
because you don't want to mess up again
you wash your hands right yeah okay
is that fun that looks really fun
actually
it feels weird that's what flour smells
like flour and something not right
really
yeah i think that's just how raw things
smell dang the pizza dough is lucky they
get a isaac massage i want a massage
from isaac
yeah isaac gives probably one of the
best massages i've ever gotten from a
non-professional and i've gotten a lot
of massages from
non-professionals and isaac's got some
great good strength in his hands
key attribute to being a good massage
therapist
bam see what happens with that oh it's
sticky now
is sticky oh should we add more flour
we're gonna keep doing this process over
and over until we have like so much
uh dough we're gonna be making like an
extra extra extra large pizza
i'm down i'm pretty hungry are you
that's good
nice all right it's a little sticky
really work it in
break it fold it break it fold it you're
sure you're not a baker
i know how to make puff pastry oh yeah
if you want a puff pastry uh recipe i
have a couple recipes on this channel if
you want to check it out the link in the
description
yeah click whatever pops up in your face
right now
that looks pretty good what do you think
it's pretty good yeah it's soft not too
sticky
sticky or a little bit lightly flour
your work area
and a rolling pin okay wiping it down uh
can you grab
the rolling pin do you know what a
rolling pin is
this will be the work surface
we're gonna flour our work surface
so flour this so let's make this floured
up and stuff
roll the dough into a very flat circle
put some elbow grease in there
yeah oh feel it it feels nice mm-hmm
let's see if we can like start
molding the sides into a circle watch
your fingers
how do you make it into the circle i
start over
hey i'm getting hungry just staring at
this dough i've been hungry
and put it here and then very gently
genius then guinness world record you
turn it this way
[Music]
guinness world record and then we turn
it this way again
[Music]
yeah the sound effects help to make make
noises out of your mouth power of the
pizza
like ninja turtles pizza power meant
something to a 90s kid
2008 kid i feel sorry for you because
it's not fun seeing the two
a 2 000 kid it's way funnier to say 80s
kid 90s kid 2
000 kid is not very fun to say that's
funny is it okay
true true true i'm a future kid you're
the future kid now we're in the 20s
so kids nowadays some guys say i'm a 20s
kid so before we continue this is the
moment that isaac's been waiting for
isaac wanted to make pizza from scratch
primarily to do this one thing and that
one thing is
tossing it up into the air yes try it
don't do not drop it on the floor though
they spin it in the air
and spin it sometimes you see this in
new york you don't really see this in la
though
are we funny if like there's a ceiling
fan above us summon the italian powers
go nice oh
[Music]
yeah we got this guy so all this excess
on the sides i'm thinking we roll it
later after we put
the sauce and the cheese and the
pepperoni go for it just don't over
pour i think that's good now take a
wooden spoon and yes if you want your
pizza extra
saucy you want to have a sausage pizza
then
we can add more sauce then this is fun
this is a great idea isaac yeah
i've been wanting to do this yeah but we
never had the time
i know can i use my hand if you want
it's
more fun that way too who needs spoons
and you got fingers
you want some more oliver twist you've
never seen all of the twists before have
you
hmm because every time i do that i feel
like you're like i don't know
oliver twist is like stuck in my mind
the only line i know from that movie is
i want some more now open up this
mozzarella cheese
now you just got all your mochas all
over it
okay get it all over there cheese
lots of it i can't tell if they're
knocking for you because i remember
hearing them knock for you
oh yeah so it's been kind of confusing
sometimes with the construction workers
here
sometimes they're asking me a question
and so they're knocking on the door
and they're in the backyards or they're
not knocking the backyard door so
there's no uh
doorbell in order to get back around to
the front of our house it's a bit of a
complicated situation because
there's like walls on both sides of our
house so we can't the only way to get to
the front of the house into the back of
the house is through the house
whoa that is a lot of cheese in one pile
found out a strategy oh you have a
little
like like a spoon a spoon of cheese you
could spoon the cheese on
looks pretty good all right it looks
like a pizza to me all right next step
pepperoni man how many pepperonis do you
think we need
however many you want this is your own
pizza there's no rules
do you want like you want so much
pepperoni that there's no cheese being
shown on the pizza
go for it you want to double layer it up
with pepperoni pepperoni
on pepperoni gopher you want to do
pepperoni and then put more cheese on
top and then
another layer of pepperoni go for you
want a pizza lasagna
go for it you want okay wow that looks
so good already
if we had a brand deal with prego this
would be a really cool shot
[Music]
but not sponsor so go away you
a lot of pepperoni yeah i'm surprised i
didn't put more
now this is the part where i'm thinking
this is how you make a crust
we roll it up take the edge it's
overflowing
and then you kind of just roll it
into the insides of the pan if that
makes sense yeah
and we got ourselves a pizza crust yeah
i actually think you're right because
this is pretty logically
correct sweet that looks like a pizza oh
man i'm so happy with this now i'm
always proud even if something that
doesn't come out right when i cook
i'm still proud because i've put in the
effort and time to try and learn it all
right
nice and toasty in there what i put
exactly
on the top shelf yeah
nice perfect that's it close it
bake the pizza for 15 minutes to 17
minutes or until golden brown
slice and enjoy it says hey siri
set timer for 16 minutes 16 minutes
starting now
yay perfect all right let's clean up
while we wait for our pizza
to bake open can
[Music]
you want to take a look take a pee look
at that
it looks pretty good the pepperoni looks
really good crust isn't crusting up
no not yet but i will give it some time
but i think we're only like three
minutes in
ten hey siri how much time is left
the timer has nine minutes in nine
minutes that's gonna be
a beautiful beautiful pizza pie
and then we'll finish it we'll eat it
grub on it
hey siri stop look at that that looks
good so i don't know if you know but hot
things coming out the oven
cannot go right on top of the table
because the heat will warp
the table and what not in the materials
so i got this guy
let's place that guy right on top of
this guy
[Music]
oh that looks good even the cheese like
got a little burnt on top i like it
dang look at his pizza look at this
pizza man
it's such a good looking pizza that's
such a good looking pizza i'm going to
take a picture of it our first
pizza so this is the infamous digiorno
pizza platter that we got from all those
digiorno brand deals we did oh those
were the days
i have a feeling this is gonna taste a
lot better than digiorno you know why
how come it's made with love bye my son
isaac that is a flavor you cannot
replace
[Music]
bam oh i see myself hey the crust
hardened
yeah that's their picture
this is our picture you gotta get a
sharper one
oh the crunch broke off do you think
that's good or yeah let's make it
smaller
what's up to you you want some big
slices no not really
okay does it look pizza
there we go nice beautiful get a plate
grab a plate grab a plate grab a plate i
used to like cream soda too but then
i changed over the years look at that oh
you already got the tv going
what are you watching spongebob
spongebob i'ma get a cream soda too
might as well might as well this is a
momentous occasion where my son made
pizza for me
calls for a cream soda celebration
let's do a toast to an awesome summer of
growth and reflection
yeah or just to pizza
pizza it's a good time oh cream soda
all right here we go oh my gosh how does
it feel how does it feel it feels nice
look at the back what does it look like
right here oh
nice close-up of the pizza
all right let's take a bite all right
here we go two one
not bad not bad yeah it's flavorful
the cheese in that was pretty good
cheese and mine's really good
sauce smells pretty good too now my
expectations for this pizza was actually
really
low mm-hmm me too i thought i'm gonna be
a fail mm-hmm
very pizza-like mm-hmm you did a good
job with the
cheese in that too yeah because when
you're doing it at first i was like
that's too much
that's too much but then now that i'm
eating i'm like oh this is a good amount
but i did have to say one thing about
this pizza
is the dough the useless version of
pizza dough you can taste the flour
more yeah you definitely taste like a
homemade thing so maybe we did the yeast
next time try making pizza and i think
if we put in like
butter or like more oil into the dough
and make it a little more like flavorful
that would be pretty good too you could
get the oil is good mm-hmm
we should say some for uh mama yeah
there we go
and there you go guys that's our pizza
video what else should we make
that we see in like stores oh yeah
we made homemade fudge mm-hmm i think
not ramen no that tastes like day weeks
about two i mean
about the same amount you have to like
boil like
pork bones or beef bones for like hours
in order to get that broth going
what do you think about pizza like
compared to hamburgers i like hamburgers
a little better we can make tacos nuts
mm-hmm crunchy tacos
we gotta make that taco bell meat i'm
down we gotta get corn
and skim yeah we gotta make that fake
meat mm-hmm
oh you know we should make a cow zone
yeah that's what we should do next
calzones
all right calzones what wait for that
video
so comment down in the comment section
what you want to see what are we called
it should be a show okay we're making a
show right now let's do it
isaac's cooking show tina i'm like okay
all right it's isaac's show here
it's isaac casey cooking show
your name your name starts with this
ends of the scene my name starts with
the scene oh this
could be called it i was like icky
cooking cooking show
thanks for watching click the link down
in the description for the
dawn top oh yeah non-tons the curry
puffs like and subscribe
if you want more of these uh cooking
[Music]
shows
[Music]
me